John Travolta wanted to bring the
central mythology of Scientology to life
with Battlefield Earth instead he
created one of the worst movies of all
time and gave a completely bizarre
performance on The Bargain Battlefield
Earth is about a terrible race of
dreadlocked aliens who have enslaved
Humanity Travolta's stars as a main bad
guy tell Travolta decided tur was a guy
who loved a good laugh Doling out his
version of an evil chuckle in almost
every scene
I do what I can
[Laughter]
if the goal was to make these gross
aliens as unappealing as possible then
Travolta actually did a perfect job
a job we never want to watch again